hello everyone welcome today's live
broadcast standards for microbiome and
metagenomics supporting the commercial
translation of microbiome plans I am
Kristin correction teal of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots for more information please visit
Margaret's com we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left is
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we begin you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window and if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left this is an
educational webinar and less offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the C
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credit I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
Jason crawl dr. Jason crawl has worked
at NIST since 2006 and as a member of
the complex microbial systems group led
by Scott Jackson currently he is
developing a pathogen DNA reference
material to address some of the
analytical challenges facing next
generations sequel sequencing-based
metagenomics I will now turn it over to
dr. crawl for his presentation
hi as you said my name is Jason crawl
I'm from the complex Microsystems group
at NIST and today I'm going to talk
about our current and future work
regarding the development of reference
materials from meta genomic analyses for
mixed microbial samples to support
commercialization of microbiome science
my co-authors on this talk are Sam flory
and Scott Jackson first on a big thank
you to all the people who helped us out
over the last year plus including
friends at FDA ikea Chelsea and Brittany
as well as it affected missed including
a golson friends at atlanta and why
global cosmos ID I'm sure there's many
others I'd forgotten I apologize keeping
to it who is missed the national
institute of standards and technology is
a non-regulatory federal agency in
between the Department of Commerce we've
been around for a little over a hundred
years with main campuses in Gaithersburg
Boulder Colorado and we have about a
staff of 5,000 students five thousand
scientists our mission is to broadly
boost the US innovation and industrial
competitiveness by balancing measure by
dancing measurements standards and
technology which of course benefits the
economy and everyone's quality of life
one of the ways we fulfill our mission
is to the development of reference
materials typically these are adopted by
community consensus in this particular
work we interface with regulatory
agencies such as the FDA and industrial
partners to understand both sets of
stakeholder needs to be able to address
the challenges associated with NGS
various metagenomic tools and how to
bring those to market
the first example where the FDA called
upon missed to support sequencing-based
technologies was with regard to human
genome sequencing we have to M stood
that if there was going to be certain
NGS based Diagnostics they need to have
confidence in the tools ability to do
exactly what they purport to do and so
they called upon this to help out with
that effort dr. Zook and salad helped
lead miss effort in this arena and have
had a major impact especially in regards
to accuracy of bass calls within the
genome the combination of reference
materials the actual physical materials
and the reference data is what makes
this such a powerful tool for the
community and of course it never hurts
when you're in your work is highlighted
in New York Times I missed very much
appreciate that we also support the
national microbiome initiative or the
mmm I that was just announced last year
I made 13 2016 and it seeks to first
answer fundamental questions about
microbiomes and diverse ecosystems to
help generate insights to help share
acknowledge of micro biomes and enhance
access to data and to engage the
community publicly through citizen
science and education there's been
considerable attention the resources
devoted to space in the recent years and
our own group is certainly funded from
part of this in order to understand the
community needs we've engaged our
stakeholders through workshops our
recent one was a focused of first one on
microbiome focused workshop was August
at 2016 was attended by academic
government and industrial stakeholders
and was a two-day workshop with roughly
200 participants focusing on talent is
all along metagenomic and
conscious pipeline as you see it that'd
be a link for the workshop up if you
want to go look there's two days we
recorded liquidity presentations and
about a year before that in October of
2015 we can beam a workshop to discuss
pathogen detection issues I will fork
for this workshop is now online and the
summary from this is that by consensus
we agree that there is a clear need for
reference materials the frames we were
going to select we're going to focus
towards clinical applications and the
particular aspects of which scream you
selected which strains pardon me we're
going to largely be driven by the
challenges associated with the
sequencing and identifying at these
organisms so looking a lot at new
neighbors hi-lo GC content limits of
detection quantification etc the next
workshop is appointed for this is going
to be in August of 2017 I'll talk about
that more later by that time we'll have
materials to share with all of you we're
also working with the agency c and FDA
to ensure that we're striking the right
balance of complexity while maintaining
abuse for everybody and satisfying the
needs of the regulatory oversight
meanwhile we're going to continue to see
stakeholder input to ensure that we're
staying true to the needs of this space
the FDA also recently published guidance
on this topic highlighting the fact that
the components of NGS based infectious
disease Diagnostics are subject to
review and as such our interpretation of
that was that Miss needs to play an
important role in our reference material
development and that's mainly to improve
the characterization of the analytical
sensitivity and specificity of these
systems or as they are known that the
FDA devices here we've outlined several
factors that contribute to some of the
16s based medicine omics uncertainty and
General Administration some of the parts
such as sequencing can have protocols
that are very literally locked down and
very well understood due to the kits and
the automation that are commonly
currently available at the same time
there are protocols and steps that can
be quite unique to the individual tasks
at hand this is not just a necessity
this is oftentimes a very good thing
it's very targeted towards the
application and rather than tell people
what they're doing right or wrong we
want to give the researchers the tools
that they need to characterize including
those steps to help them understand
which parts of the of the process of
critical to ensuring for disability and
to make their analysis portable to
others so these are some of the elements
that help enable analytical sensitivity
and specificity I should note this is by
no means an exhaustive list just many of
the ones that sort of came to mind very
quickly I'm even looking at the whole
metagenomics process more bought more
broadly and this would include both
shotgun metagenomics as well 16s
sequencing there are multiple points
where characterization and calibration
are required clearly our efforts are
only going to address a portion of this
challenge so this condensed workflow
identifies how we commonly translate a
sample into something into a report or
something we can understand or
potentially even act upon the organisms
with make this workflow the organism's
DNA would be extracted purified the
nucleic acids would then be sequenced
and then the computational tools would
attempt to identify which organisms each
DNA fragment came from and along this
process they're going biases or errors
that are introduced and propagate
throughout the entire analysis in order
to understand where and how these biases
affecting results we work backwards this
enables the developers and evaluators
can confidently focus as they go further
and further upstream to what are known
to be suspected or known
legions of high variability in the
process hence we chosen to start with
DNA as the to analyze that for the
sequencing informatics steps we realized
that none of these mixtures rather than
any of these niches we create are likely
to be artificial simple and unlikely to
reflect what are real samples even so
this is a first step in this process is
designed to assess general performance
we're not trying to assess organism
specific identity at this point second
is to acknowledge that this material is
not going to help us characterize the
pre-analytical variables such as
extraction as you saw on the previous
slide there's a lot to be understood in
this analysis moving forward eventually
missing our partners may seek to
establish whole-cell microbial mixtures
that mimic and complement the DNA
reference materials which would likely
be designed around understanding a lot
of really analytical variables but we
also know the sequencing informatics
steps typically work well although it's
sometimes that intersection may be
difficult to characterize and there can
be problems such as sequencing errors
and database creation the law sometimes
played certain analyses here i'm posting
the list of our proposed reference
material of bacterial strains this list
is subject to change will continuously
evaluating materials that are being
produced to ensure that they're going to
meet the stringent needs of our
stakeholders and with both the Cure
inequality that everyone's expecting big
thanks to the FDA doctors campus at
Children's Hospital and chew at UCSF
they've been indispensable in helping us
make selections for this list and it
represents a broad range of pathogens
and commensals that can be signify or
represented different diseases and taxa
including the lot from your neighbor's
variable to seek on
some drug resistance and i want to
emphasize here this material is designed
for pathogen detection it's not intended
as a mock community and the deliverables
for this only be vials of DNA not whole
cells however we anticipate the material
can and will be used in a variety of
microbiome studies because some even
many of the screens listed are likely to
show up in a lot of the analyses and
could serve as appropriate controls to
characterize the reference material
we're going to establish the lead
concentration which will be combined
with assembled genomes to help us
estimate the genome copies per
microliter something to that effect
we'll do a base level purity and
characterize the genomic contamination
and of course will characterize the
stability much of this work will take
some time and there's potential for
collaboration with sequencing centers
and implementations to help us Parsons
results and interpret them when making a
modular pen with bacterial DNA in
individual tubes so when asked what is
the mix of microbial canary material and
they look like important to note that
it's going to be left unmixed we
intentionally did that because that's
what the community wanted even though
it's likely introduced some
heterogeneity and uncertainty analysis
the folks who who are stakeholders
insisted business the best option for
them we're sure that people are going to
come up with new ways to use this
material and this will hopefully allow
researchers to extend the use of
material in the areas that we haven't
even thought of the idea here is that
tubes one through twenty-four
twenty-five will be microbial strains
and then we'll also include include ash
in genomic DNA component that's part of
the background looking forward one of
the future expansions of this is likely
to be viral components most viral
genomes aren't really an option to
include here because of safety and
export controls
working with diamond manufacturers to
figure out what Tim can't be done see
what we can distribute these without
special licensing it also highlights the
flexibility of this modular design
because we'll be able to incorporate new
components of this with while supporting
the legacy components and also think
that working closely with stakeholders
of the nmi other standards meeting what
specific needs could also be developed
possibly with or including new materials
and incorporate best practices women
from the design of this set can you
begin any reference material you're
likely to make some sort of mixture of
DNA and work the samples up to run on
your favorite sequencing or PCR
platforms and take that data and run
through whatever software you've
designed to align it and in this
particular hypothetical maybe you would
mix a pathogen DNA with some human DNA
run it on a sequencer or conceal a
platform or maybe both and do some kind
of response code to generate an
estimation of the abundance of the
species or generate some kind of
calibration curve for your protocol the
important part in all of this is the
first one that you have an understanding
of the ground truth of your sample of
what's in it it should become easier for
you to interpret the results and
identify the strengths and weaknesses of
any particular analysis you would select
there are several ways when visions the
material could be used secretly
sequencing the isolates is one way to
check the pipeline because it's simple
allows you to understand your process
with specific organisms but the real
power is to be able to be mixture
designs so Latin square type experiments
which I've shown here on the right doing
some poorly organisms representative
different concentrations across
different mixtures which can provide not
only a wealth of information about
system performance especially when it
comes to limit of detection limits upon
quantification what we show in this
simple experiment
sample experiment is a combination of
epigenomic sorry right it's a
combination of the epigenomic and log 10
deletions which one could multiplex on a
single sequence in one even many things
start to ask questions like can you
detect organism x and y what about Y and
X does the preference of presidents of
one organism even affect another's
detection what about spiking material
into a known material or even unknown
sample to help provide some sort of
reference signal in addition these
material needs to test the informatics
as well and these being the taxonomic ID
methods and comparisons can we move
beyond identity into qualification we
start to answer the kinds of questions
that you see from regulators so having
well characterized materials will our
developers and users alike to have
confidence that the tools that they're
developing have the analytical
sensitivity and specificity that their
applications require amusing to some
obvious examples certainly there are
other complex mixtures that would stress
the capabilities of NGS based
metagenomics analysis in a variety of
ways and we think the community is going
to work hard to find many of them we
need to dig into the data as I'm sure
many of you have you start to realize
there is a lot going on when you tried
to conceptually break this up into into
some of the components so that we can
classify what's in the data some of it
is going to be accurately sequence and
here I call this the real stuff which is
comprised of not only the actual sample
that was in there but also in the
contaminants and chimeric sequences that
might have formed during library prep on
the other side some of the data will
have artifacts due to things such as
sequencing errors or potentially
mistakes or missions in the database and
we know even some labs like track trends
with which instrument was used for
sequencing who prepped what who did the
run etc so they can I be additional
contaminants
and false positives and we think this is
great we think this is exactly what I
should be doing to sort of home in on
the uncertainty in your analyses that's
good measurement science and we want to
help support that we also hope that the
reference material will have all of you
do the same in mission more or maybe
potentially all the sources of
variability and bias in the informatics
tools and sequencing clearly our
reference material isn't the last word
because it doesn't address a lot of the
premium article variables that we
discussed earlier but it is the
beginning so here is an example of one
implementation of the mixer design the
sequence an economic mixture of some of
our existing reference materials which
contain for bacteria and ones in genome
where we knew into the individual
abundances which of these on women on my
seats using the next to the XT kit we
took the data and ran them through two
taxonomic identification tools here
using the back of a blast plus pwa from
gotcha and gotcha species database to
show how the different outputs can look
when we run through different algorithms
and you see critter differences between
the methods and that one gets more
apparent false positives again we know
before organisms that remember this or
rather the five organisms that went into
it but there's obviously more than that
here and not only the false positive but
how perhaps better sensitivity with the
first one so it seems to maybe be a
trade-off but both have false negatives
we know that we included plus students
progenies in this but it showed up
immediate case so in very much different
results using different valuation
criteria
let me piss data in a slightly different
way taking the same equity moment
mixtures here on plotting relative
abundance as best we could determine it
using the output of each of the tool are
considered so here we have a list of six
some of which I redactor the names of
normalizing the data to the salmonella
enterica for only the organisms which we
selected so we've excluded all of the
false positives to just focus on sort of
what we were looking at the black bars
represent what we input and as you can
see is general agreement between most of
the tools of what was there with the
exception be a cluster de Mirage anees
has been previously mentioned and we
followed up with the tool designers we
found that most of them did not include
this organism in your database so not
surprisingly it went undetected and it
was assigned and or was assigned an
identity of something else we think this
kind of insight is a lot of what the
community will encountering the real
samples we can identify a lot of things
we know pretty well that there are still
blind spots and if a tool doesn't have a
good match either likely to get in on my
own or a miss assignment and one of
those is not necessarily better than the
other having a tool that points to a
particular organism could give a
research for a lead on where to look a
little closer maybe did and find an
organism that would have a better match
or lead you to other non
sequencing-based Diagnostics to follow
up with on the other hand may want a
more conservative tool for applications
with clinical nurse diagnosis and this
treatment would have poor outcomes or
bad effects and all of this is to say
that these simple mixtures don't always
look so simple the data aren't simple to
interpret and many of the microbiome
samples that are out there are far far
more complex than these and really this
is like standard cell even though each
platform may report different metrics
it's necessary that the sensitivity and
specificity of the methods are well
understood for objective allegation of
the
performance so missed aims to deliver
measurement assurance tools standardized
protocols reference materials validated
measurements and critically evaluated
reference data the rollout of this
material will happen during the summer
expecting June to take delivery of
purified DNA material we will do
baseline sequencing run on the material
to ensure it is what we think it is and
start to assemble the the genomes and
performs an analysis of the kick the can
characterize the concentration we then
plan to make the material available in
August ago it will be a reference
material at the time we'll continue to
assess the material using deep
sequencing will certainly look to
collaborate with people who hold of it
fully assemble the genome and also
develop to pcr assays to further
strengthen the quantification of the
material going forward another major
aspect to this material is that it works
best when the entire community buys into
it so crowdsourcing we want to work
together through in a lot of studies for
not only producing data but to also help
develop best practices in terms of
mixture models and figuring out what
suits the needs of maybe the majority or
just a lot of the applications ordering
into space releasing game that reference
materials are really at their most
powerful when they're being measured
many times in many ways by many people
and as such we want to hear from you in
particular if you're a sequencing
requirement for medics lab as we
mentioned earlier and as they also
mentioned earlier we have a workshop
coming up in august the purpose of this
workshop is to present state of the art
pathogen detection technologies
emphasize meetings for standards
relevant to clinical diagnostics and by
the threat detection stakeholder
communities speakers will include
subject matter experts in the industry
academia and government and part of that
will be to update on the progress of our
DNA
the reference material and part of that
is we're helping to send everybody home
with a panel of our of our test material
so if you want more information please
follow the link legislation should be
available now and this line if you need
any help and so to conclude we know
there's a clearing for microbial
reference materials for NGS base and
another genomics and detection mist will
be making our first panel available in
August it will consist of 25 strains of
bacteria plus one human and is designed
for pathogens it will obviously include
microbiome strands as part of this as
well the reference materials will help
assess mgs performance of these michael
in nature's targeting analytical
sensitivity and specificity for in this
case specifically packet injection but
obviously applies God is not
additionally will enable evaluation of
the existing pipelines for their
suitability to handle these different
kinds of samples and finally we want to
be a community resource to olive you
want your interactions and your input so
please come to our workshop and contact
us for additional collaborations with
that I would like to thank you and take
any questions
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can and our
first question is how do you quantify
low-level abundance using your materials
so how do you quantify low-level
abundance yeah that's really one of the
big questions that comes back to us and
the answer to that I think is largely it
depends there's a number of ways you
could do it you wouldn't necessarily
need a reference material to do that you
could take a control screen that you
have and quantify the DNA and dilute it
down and run your sequencing analysis on
that too to try and assess where the
limit of detection is for each specific
organism and I think that's important to
note is that each organism is likely to
have its own particular limit of
detection especially with regard to not
only the matrix that you working in but
also the combination of other organisms
very likely present so it's really a
case-by-case basis okay and far for our
next question what are your plans for
including whole cells in the future will
they be the same organisms
so we know there are a number of
standards and materials out there
already that you can go search on your
own we aren't looking to make those
materials ourselves at this point we are
looking at working with some of the
other companies who have their own
strange to see if that would work atcc
has expressed some interest I believe of
the don't quote me on that in producing
a reference material containing these
organisms as well I'm sure there are
other companies out there who also have
other mock communities that they would
like to see incorporated a lot of
pipeline analysis if there are no more
questions I would like to once again
thank thank dr. crawl for his
presentation do you have any final
comment none for me thank you for the
opportunity to speak today and good luck
thank you doctor crawl today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through October of 2017 you will receive
an email from Lavery's alerting you when
this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward the
announcements to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event we'll see
you next time goodbye
you